ende des steuer dumpings großkonzerne
sollen bald weltweit mindeststeuer
zahlen überall wo sie gewinne machen
vor dem ansturm ab montag dürfen sich
alle zur impfung anmelden aber nicht
jeder wird soweit rankommen und immer
wieder gewitter sturm und starkregen
richten fast im ganzen land erhebliche
schäden an
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg den abend und herzlich
willkommen an meiner seite ist für den
sportmediziner oder anderen mit formel 1
guten abend schon lange geht es als
unfair dass technologie konzerne wie
amazon oder apple so wenig steuern auf
ihre gigantischen gewinne zahlen
jetzt feiern die g7-finanzminister einen
zitat historischen durchbruch
sie haben sich auf das ziel einer
mindeststeuer von mindestens 15% für
großkonzerne geeinigt die unternehmen
sollen künftig auch dort steuern zahlen
wo sie umsatz machen
andreas stamm hat mehr weniger
kapitalismuskritische demonstranten am
mittag in london
denn die bühne gehört in dieser stunde
anderen den finanzministern der
führenden industrienationen die sich
nach vielen anläufen auf eckpunkte für
ein gerechteres internationales
steuersystem einigen eine historische
vereinbarung einer reform die das system
fit macht für das globale digitale
zeitalter sicherstellt dass es fair ist
jede firma die geforderten steuern zahlt
und zwar am richtigen ort
künftig soll eine globale mindeststeuer
entrichtet werden in höhe von 15 prozent
auf sämtliche unternehmensgewinne
weltweit das heißt wenn beispielsweise
ein deutsches unternehmen im ausland
etwa den niederlanden nur ein prozent
auf seine gewinne entrichtet fordert der
deutsche fiskus die restlichen 14
prozent ein
gewinne verschieben in steueroasen würde
unattraktiv globale konzerne die
milliarden verdienen aber kaum steuern
zahlen soll es künftig nicht mehr geben
ebenso soll verhindert werden dass
länder firmen mit niedrigen steuern
locken und dabei mithelfen dass gewinne
verschoben und klein gerechnet werden
die einigung zeigt die neue us-regierung
ist wieder offen für internationale
zusammenarbeit und die amerikanische
finanzministerium sucht wie alle nach
einnahmequellen um pandemie bedingte
haushaltslöcher zu stopfen
dass wir unter den g7 ländern so weit
kommen das wäre noch vor einem jahr
nicht absehbar gewesen das ist jetzt ein
zug der sich in bewegung gesetzt hat er
wird nicht mehr aufzuhalten sein
die g7 vereint zuversichtlich dass man
140 länder darunter rivalen wie china
oder bisherige profiteure wie die
schweiz überzeugen wird was noch mal
dauern dürfte
die chance auf ein gerechteres
steuersystem war nie größer
bitte haben sie geduld so der
eindringliche appell von ärzten sie
befürchten einen weiteren ansturm von
impfwilligen auf ihre praxen
denn ab montag fällt die bundesweite
priorisierung beck dann kann sich
grundsätzlich jeder impfen lassen
allerdings halten etliche bundesländer
wegen langer wartezeiten noch an der
reihenfolge fest dass ab kommende woche
auch die betriebsärzte impfen dürfen
hilft nur begrenzt auch sie haben nicht
genug dosen mehr hat irgendwer hamburg
im juni kroner ist noch da aber auch die
hoffnung auf ein bald wieder normales
leben viele warten noch auf die impfung
einigen dauert das zu lange
natürlich ist man genervt aber langsam
ist natürlich die geduld irgendwie
vorbei kein verständnis wir also ich
kann ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen dass
dass ich meine das gerät im jahr also
über ein ja da sollte man doch irgendwie
ihre lage sein das so zu schaffen dass
alle geimpft werden können montag
stichtag für frustrierte jeder darf sich
dann um einen impftermin bemühen ein
ansturm auf die praxen wird befürchtet
in den praxen selber wird es sicherlich
warteschlangen und geben
deswegen raten wir davon ab am montag
gleich die praxis zu stürmen sondern ja
man kann anrufen aber man muss damit
rechnen dass länger dauert und wenn man
wird mit sicherheit erst mal auf einer
warteliste dann sowie in den impfzentren
auch hier in hamburg will man trotz im
freigabe erst die höheren priorisierung
gruppen versorgen impfstoffe alle dafür
reicht es noch lange nicht in der
nächsten woche gehen etwa 3,4 millionen
impfstoff in die hausarztpraxen 25
millionen an die impfzentren und neu
auch 700.000 zu den betriebsärzten
respektable zahlen trotzdem werden
wieder viele leer ausgehen der eben
stoff ist zurzeit noch so knapp dass wir
nicht so schnell impfen können wie die
menschen es wollen und wie es unsere
strukturen auch könnte das begrenzende
teil der impfkampagne ist nach wie vor
der impfstoff die geduldprobe impfen
geht also weiter
heftige kritik gibt es an
gesundheitsminister sparen wegen neuer
masken vorwürfe nach einem spiegel
bericht hatte sein ministerium im
frühjahr 2020 für eine milliarde euro
nur unzureichend getestete corona
schutzmasken gekauft und dann überlegt
sie an obdachlose und behinderte zu
verteilen
das ministerium sagt es sei dabei nicht
um eine vertriebsidee gegangen
der bestmögliche schutz der bürger habe
jederzeit im vordergrund gestanden
in der pandemie werden in vielen ländern
deutlich weniger organe gespendet wegen
überlasteter intensivstationen in
deutschland sind die zahlen relativ
stabil geblieben allerdings und das ist
die wichtige nachricht am tag der
organspende
immer noch warten mehr als 9000 menschen
auf ein spenderorgan
verena kerth akutes nierenversagen mit
danach war für peter man alles anders
dialyse warteliste für ein spenderorgan
mittlerweile hat der 44 jährige zweimal
eine nierenspende erhalten die ersten
fünf die zweite 13 jahre an den
zwiespalt vor dem transplantationen
erinnert er sich genau die op hinterher
wenn er auf der intensivstation liegt
funktioniert alles wird das organ direkt
angenommen oder jetzt abgestoßen vom
körper seit drei jahren wartet er auf
seine dritten ihre petermann ist
risikopatient mit corona hat er sich
noch stärker isoliert mittlerweile ist
er geimpft aber damit ein spender organ
nicht abgestoßen wird muss das
immunsystem gebremst werden
deshalb sind die impfstoffe bei
organempfänger nicht so wirksam wie bei
gesunden
das ist leider sehr schade liegt aber
daran dass wir ja bei organempfänger
immunantwort gegen ein neues organ
verhindern wollen
und genau das machen wir halt auch wir
verhindern die immunantwort gegen einen
neuen des antigen gegen einen neuen
erreger und da müssen wir so die genaue
dosis finden in seinem arm einstand ein
fest installierter zugang der dialyse
ermöglicht dreimal in der woche das team
petermann realisieren
er will unbedingt zurück zu einem alltag
ohne blutwäsche ich wollte auf den anruf
dass hoffentlich bald wieder ein
transplantat da ist und ich mich fertig
machen kann meine tasche packen und hier
noch kommen busch komme und dann
hoffentlich ein gutes langlebiges
transplantaten kommen das warten ist
immer im hinterkopf die hoffnung dass es
schnell geht hält eher klein
morgen ist die letzte landtagswahl vor
der bundestagswahl in sachsen anhalt bis
zuletzt hieß es für alle parteien noch
mal wähler mobilisieren
umfragen zufolge liegt die cdu von
ministerpräsident haseloff vorn er würde
gern im amt bleiben
die afg könnte erneut zweitstärkste
kraft werden
ob es eine neuauflage der kenya
koalition geben wird ist offen
und bettina schausten in unserem
wahlstudio in magdeburg sachsen anhalt
ist auch für überraschungen gut
ja und ist kein leichtes pflaster für
wahlforscher von interesse wird vor
allem sein ob bzw wieweit
ministerpräsident haseloff die afg auf
abstand halten kann
denn dass seine cdu wohl die nase vorn
haben wird davon geht die
forschungsgruppe wahlen nach den letzten
messungen recht sicher aus
je deutlicher die cdu führt umso
erfreulicher der wahl am natürlich auch
für den cdu kanzler kandidaten armin
laschet die überhaupt diese wahl für
alle bundes parteien ein letzter
stimmungstest ist vor der wahl im
september
also wer kann was und wieviel aus
sachsen-anhalt mitnehmen in den
anstehenden wahlkampf das wird morgens
sicher heiß diskutiert werden wir melden
uns ab 17 uhr 45 hier aus dem zerfall
studio und magdeburg bis dann dankeschön
bettina schausten noch bis morgen auf
die synagoge von ulm ist offenbar ein
brandanschlag verübt worden
baden württembergs ministerpräsident
kretschmann sprach von einer
niederträchtigen tat
sie zeige das heimtückische gesicht des
antisemitismus
ein zeuge hatte beobachtet wie ein
unbekannter an der fassade flüssigkeit
ausschüttete und anzündete
der schaden blieb gering auch die
feuerwehr sofort anrückte
seit gestern abend entlädt sich über
deutschland ein gewitter nach dem
anderen außerdem nordosten konnte es so
gut wie jede gegend treffend heute etwa
bat aber auch in niederbayern
nach einem kurzen aber sehr heftigen
schauer wurde der ort teilweise
überspült noch mehr regen ging gestern
über hennef bei bonn nieder
durch ganze straßenzüge schoss das
wasser und der schlamm ergoss sich in
etliche häuser nicht schönreden da hat
sie tennisspieler in paris deutlich
es habe deutlich besser und da konnte
ein deutscher wieder strahlen nach
alexander zverev hat jan lennard struff
als zweiter deutscher das achtelfinale
der french open in paris erreicht
der 31 jährige tennis profi aus warstein
sieg gegen den spanier carlos alcaraz in
drei sätzen
deutschlands nummer zwei steht damit zum
zweiten mal unter den besten 16 in paris
gegen den 18 jährigen carlos alcaraz
agiert jan lennard struff konzentriert
und konsequent gewinnt satz eins mit 6
zu führen das spanische top talent aber
bleibt ein frecher furchtloser parteien
vielleicht sogar ein zukünftiger
champion und hast du sicher dass er
wirklich ein top top top spieler wird in
der zukunft war gutes match heute gegend
offen gegner und bin sehr glücklich im
zweiten durchgang muss der deutsche den
satzball abwehren gewinnt im tie break
am ende steht ein souveräner dreisatz
erfolg im achtelfinale wartet auf struff
der argentinier diego schwarzmann hat
nummer zehn gesetzt
celik leer startet von der pole position
in den großen preis von aserbaidschan
der 23-jährige ferrari pilot setzt sich
im qualifying auf dem stadtkurs von baku
gegen rekord weltmeister lewis hamilton
und wm spitzenreiter max verstanden
durch
der viermalige weltmeister sebastian
vettel geht in erster martin von
startplatz elf ins sechste saisonrennen
war den finales ging es heute in zwei
sportarten um deutsche meistertitel die
in tokio erstmals zum olympischen
programm gehören schneller als ein
fahrstuhl sprintet franziska ritter aus
wuppertal die wand hinauf 8,1 62
sekunden damit ist sie zum dritten mal
nacheinander deutsche meisterin beim
trial bike ist dominik oswald eine
klasse für sich der weltmeister
absolviert auf seinem 20 zoll rad
fehlerfrei den kurs in berlin und krönt
sich erneut mit dem nationalen titel
der jubelschrei war noch drauf ist
beeindruckend das wetter bleibt
gewittrig nicht nur aber vor allem in
bayern die details hat gleich katja um
viertel vor elf ist zeit fürs heute
journal mit marietta slomka
hier geht es gleich weiter mit live
leichtathletik von den final ihnen noch
ein schönes wochenende und bis morgen
wenn sie müssen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren auch
heute entwickelten sich ab dem späten
vormittag kräftige schauer und gewitter
schwerpunkt diesmal hier zwischen dem
harz und franken
und genau in dieser region von der
nordseeküste bis zum alpenrand erwarten
uns jetzt auch am abend und in der nacht
zum teil kräftige gewitter schwerpunkt
liegt in bayern und auch morgen bleibt
es bei dieser wetter drei teile im
nordosten ist es sonnig und trocken
dann geht es diesen gewittrigen streifen
schwerpunkt wieder in bayern
im westen sind die wolken dichter zeigen
kaum mal die sonne dafür gibt es
regenschauer die temperaturen sind
zweigeteilt zwischen dem erzgebirge und
ostsee steigen sie auf 23 bis 28 grad
sonst wird es bei 16 bis 22 grad weniger
warm und die nächste woche startet ganz
ähnlich schön aber noch